[موسيقى]
علق ثلاثه 33 عاملا في منجم سانخوسي في
التشيلي لمده ثلاثه 33 يوما وقد بدات
اعمال انقاظهم يوم الثالث عشر من الشهر
العاشر من عام 2010 وهي ارقام اذا جمعت
تصبح ايضا ثلاثه وثلاثين
كتب العامل فيكتور زموا في رساله لزوجته
من غياهب المنجم اثناء محنتهم فيه انا
ابلغ اليوم ثلاثه وثلاثين عاما ونحن ثلاثه
وثلاثون عامله وسيد المسيح عليه السلام
كان يبلغ ثلاثه وثلاثين عاما من العمر
عندما انتهت رحلته الاولى في الارض
الرقبه 33
يناهز ثلث المئه والرقب
333 هو ثلث الالف
برنامج فوق السلطه يصل اليوم معكم الى
الحلقه التي تحمل الرقم
يقولون ان رحله الالف ميل تبدا بخطوه
ونقول بتفاؤل وبواقعيه ورضا ما قاله الله
تعالى في سوره لقمان وما تدري نفس ماذا
تكسب غدا وما تدري نفس باي ارض تموت الى
العناوين
السودان ابتسم ايها الجنرال لقد اصبحت
ملكا على افريقيا
هل يفكر السنوار بتغيير اسمك كتائب القسام
الى كتائب الاسد
الاحتلال يهين راهبات القدس ويعرقل قداديس
كنيسه القيامه
خط الرياض دمشق مفتوح بالاتجاهين فهل يقفل
طريق الكبتاجون
سعيد يعتقل الغنوشي وباب الفاتيكان ينضم
للاخوان المسلمين في تونس
بعد الغائه تجريم الزنا وزير العدل
المغربي متهم باهانه المغربيه
قتل نائب مسلم وشقيقه في الهند على الهواء
والقتله يرددون شعارات هندوسيه
طالبته بنصف امواله لكنه قد يحصل على نصف
ثروتها اشرف حكيمي وطليقته التي اكلت
الضرب
مرحبا وعيد فطر مبارك بينما ينشغل العالم
بتطبيقات الذكاء الاصطناعي على تقنيه
الجيل الخامس كان الاخوه في السودان
يطلقون الجيل الثاني من الثورات المضاده
انقلاب المنقلبين على الانقلاب فالجسد لا
يسع قلبين والبلد لا يتحمل قائدين
فقط الموتى في القبور لم يتوقعوا اندلاع
حرب الجنرالين رئيس مجلس السياده عبد
الفتاح البرهان ونائبه محمد حمدان دقلو
حميتي لكن مساوئ الصدف انهما وعلى ما درجه
عليه التمس العشر الاخيره من رمضان زمنا
لكبيره الكبائر القتل بمعارك لم يجد اهل
العلم توصيفا لها ابلغ من الحديث النبوي
الشريف اذا التقى المسلمان بسيفيهما
فالقاتل والمقتول في النار مطامع الجنرلين
الذين روع المواطنين واشاع القتل في عشر
رمضان الاواخر تذكر بما كانا قد فعلاه في
عشر من رمضان قبل ثلاث سنوات
كان قتلا يوم ذاك من اجل السلطه وهو
اقتتال اليوم على مذبحها ايضا مبالغات
حصائد الواتساب اليوميه التي تصلنا على
هواتفنا تفوقت عليها بيانات الطرفين التي
ان جمعنا ما تضمنته من مناطق سيطر عليها
كل من الطرفين لكان علينا ان نقول لكل من
القائدين ابتسم ايها الجنرال لقد اصبحت
ملكا على افريقيا ولقد استعدت جنوب
السودان وجيشك الان يشرب من سد النهضه في
اثيوبيا وشعبك يطبخ ارز كينيا بزيت دخيل
من نيجيريا
صفحه منسوبه للجيش السوداني تعرض بدله
عسكريه تقول انها للجنرال حميتي ولم يتسنى
لنا التاكد من مطابقتها مع مقاسات حميتي
في المقابل تحدث الجنرال حميتي عن قرب
اعتقاله البرهان او تصفيته وهو يعرف مكانه
يقول ويصفه بالاسلامي المتطرف الحرب التي
اطلق الجميع رصاصتها الاولى كما علق البعض
تنقى بيانات وعواصم القرار عن التدخل بها
اعلاميا على الاقل لمصلحه طرف دون اخر على
قاعده امطر حيث شئت فالرابح ايا كان يحتاج
الى مصادقه اوراق اعتماده منها ليسود على
السودان المخلوق شعبه بسواعد العسكر
اصدرت السودان بيانات تدعو للتهدئه كان
ابرزها السفاره الامريكيه بدا ان جميع
الاطراف الخارجيه تترقب من سيحسم الصراع
فالامريكيون حتى الان وقفوا على الحياد
والروس كذلك وكلاهما قال ان على الجميع
ضبط النفس وتغليف مصلحه السودان فالخلاف
داخلي اما عن العرب فهم يترقبون ايضا
فالامر حتى الان قتال اهلي يقول طرفه انهم
تقريبا حسم صراع وكل واحد فيهم هو المنتصر
حتى وان علم الجميع ان السودان كله خاسر
والرصاصه الاولى اطلقها الجميع على صعيد
التطلعات القوميه للطرفين المتقاتلين
يحدثنا موقع اكسيوس الاخباري الامريكي ولا
حرج فالجيش السوداني يطبع مع الحكومه
الاسرائيليه اما قوات الدعم السريع فتطبع
مع
الجامعه العربيه المنشغله بمواكبه اعمال
حياكه سجاده حمراء بلون الدم ليعبر عليها
رئيس النظام السوري الى الجامعه المهجوره
تتابع اخبار السودان بالقدر الذي لا
يحرمها من متابعه نهائيات المسلسلات التي
تعرض في رمضان
يعلق معلق لكن ماذا عن مصر بعد ان ظهر
جنود لها كانوا في مهمه تدريبيه وفق
قيادتهم ظهروا في فيديو احتجاز قوات الدعم
السريع لهم في قاعده مروي شمال السودان ثم
نقلتهم هذه القوات الى الخرطوم تمهيدا
لاطلاقهم متى سنحت الفرصه بذلك كما اكد
بيان الدعم السريع وربما يكون قد اطلقوا
اثناء عرض الحلقه
قبل ايام قليله على اندلاع المعارك اقام
نائب الرئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
الجنرال حميتي مادوبه افطار حضرها الصديق
حفتر احد انجال الجنرال الليبي خليفه حفتر
بعد اختيار نادي المريخ السوداني له رئيسا
فخريا ستكون هناك نقله نوعيه لنادي المريخ
في كل في كل ملاحيه الخساره الموجعه لنادي
المريخ مع اول دخول حفتر عليه وخروجه
المبكر من البطوله العربيه لكره القدم في
السعوديه
ذكرت بطرفه الليبيه تقول ان الجنرال حفتر
لم يربح معركه قط حتى ولو على طاوله الزهر
المريخ بشكل رسمي خارج البطوله العربيه من
الدور التمهيدي الاول امام تشرين السوري
الخروج المهين بالنسبه للفريق
لقد تاكد لنا عدم صحه خبريه ان الرئيس
حركه حماس في قطاع غزه يحيى السنوار يفكر
بتغيير اسم كتائب عز الدين القسام الى
كتائب حافظ الاسد ونحن
لبناء محور القدس قدس فنتصالح مع سوريا
الاسد التي تمثل احد احد ساحات الحشد
والارتكاز وجند بالشام السنوار قدم من
خبرته السياسيه المديده توجيهات للامه
باعاده نظام الاسد الى جامعه الدول
العربيه فورا واننا نرى ان من الضروري
المنعم
عوده سوريه للجامعه العربيه ابو مرزوق
ينقى بحماس عن تصريحات السنوار هذا ما
قراته صحيفه الشرق الاوسط السعوديه في
تغريده القيادي الحمساوي موسى ابو مرزوق
الذي قال ان حركته ليست جزءا من اي محور
سياسي او عسكري في المنطقه فمن الناطق
الدقيق باسم حماس السنوار ام ابو مرزوق
الذي كان ضمن وفد من قياده حماس ضم
الرئيسى الحركه السابقه والحالي خالد مشعل
واسماعيل هنيه في مكه المكرمه يؤدون
العمره بعد موافقه السلطات السعوديه على
الزياره ولاول مره منذ عده سنوات
الزياره وان اتخذت بعدا دينيا لكنها
تزامنت مع وصول الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود
عباس الى الرياض ولقائه الملك وولي العهد
السعودي ما دفع التلفزيون الالماني الى
السؤال هل في ذلك تحريك سعودي لملف
المصالحه الفلسطينيه من قال ان الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ومستوطنيه يعادون المسلمين فقط
انهم يتربصون بكل مختلف عنهم كما يبدو
فيعقلون وصول المسيحيين المحتفلين بعيد
سبت النور الى كنيسه القيامه فيما متطرفون
بالقدس يهينون راهباتها في حاراتها
العتيقه
من جانبها اصدرت المؤسسات الكنسيه بيانا
مشتركا دانت به رفض السلطات الاسرائيليه
تنسيق احتفالات سبت النور مشاهد الاعتداء
هذه في البلده القديمه على الحجاج
والمصلين تشبه الاعتداءات التي يتعرض لها
الحجاج في كل عام ما يجري من تقارب عربي
مع النظام السوري هو اجراءات احاديه وليس
عملا جماعيا حتى الان هذه خلاصه كلام رئيس
مجلس الوزراء القطري الشيخ محمد بن عبد
الرحمن ال ثاني الذي اعاد تاكيد الموقف
القطري بان الاسباب الموضوعيه لمقاطعه
نظام دمشق ما زالت قائمه وفي شيء موجود
اليوم على الطاوله مطروح كلها تكهنات كان
هناك اسباب لتعليق عضويه سوريا في الجامعه
العربيه والتعامل ومقاطعه النظام السوري
في ذاك الوقت وهذه الاسباب ما زالت قائمه
بالنسبه اقل في دوله قطر صحيح ان الحرب
توقفت ولكن الشعب السوري ما زال مهجر في
الناس يعني ابرياء في السجون واحنا نتمنى
يعني انه يكون في حل في اسرع وقت ممكن
والحل هذا في يد السوريين وليس في الدوله
قطر اعلنت السلطات السعوديه عن ضبط ملايين
اقراص الكبتاجون المخدره مخباه في شحنه
بطاطا هذه المره وفقا لوكاله الانباء
السعوديه العمليه اكتشفت بعد ثلاث ساعات
من رحيل وزير الخارجيه السوري فيصل
المقداد عن الرياض في اول زياره من نوعها
منذ اكثر من عشر سنوات لكن زياره الابرز
كانت تلك التي قام بها وزير الخارجيه
السعودي فيصل بن فرحان الى دمشق حيث التقى
الرئيس بشار الاسد بحث مع الرئيس بشار
الاسد اجراءات تحقيق المصالحه السياسيه
التي قالا انها ستعيد سوريا الى وضعها
الطبيعي
قبل 12 سنه
[موسيقى]
رئيس حركه النهضه ورئيس برلمان تونس
المنحل راشد الغنوشي اقتيد باعوامه
الاثنتين والثمانين الى سجون قيس سعيد
المصر على ارتدائه بدله الجنرال مستعاره
من سوق الالبسه المستعمله يقولون في تونس
الى جهه غير معلومه اقتدت القوه الامنيه
راشد الغنوشي كما قالت حركه النهضه التي
يتزعمها السياسي التونسي ذو التوجهات
الاسلاميه وسائل اعلام تونسيه نقلت عن
مصادر رسميه ان الغنوشي متهم باطلاق
تصريحات تحريضيه سميه راشد الغنوشي تكشف
ان والدها الذي نقل الى المستشفى لاحقا
حرم في المعتقل من استخدام دوره المياه
فماذا لو دارت الايام دورتها تسال
المعارضه التونسيه واخر ما بلغنا منا
الاستاذ نجيب الشابي وانه في المستشفى ولا
نستبعد ذلك بلغنا انه طلب استخدام دوره
المياه فرفضوا طلبه واشترطوا ان يبقي
الباب مفتوحا
فرفض هذه الاهانه المعامله المهينه ولا
ادري ما البطوله في ان تقتاد ثمانينيا وهو
صائم في ليله السابع والعشرين من رمضان
ليله مباركه سلام هي حتى مطلع الفجر ان
تقتاده من بيته وتحرمه حتى من استخدام
دوله المياه الغنوشي سيبقى معتقلا على ذمه
التحقيق دون تحديد سقف زمنيا للاعتقال
بحسب التلفزيون التونسي الرسمي الذي اعلن
عما يشبه الشمع الاحمر تضعه سلطات سعيد
على مقرات النهضه وجبهه الخلاص المعارضه
مصدر المسؤول بوزاره الداخليه افاد ان
فرقه امنيه وباذن من النيابه العموميه
قامت بتفتيش منزل راشد الغنوشي وحجز كل ما
يفيد الابحاث مضيفا سيبقى على ذمه الابحاث
الى حين اتخاذ اجراءات بخصوصه لم يوضح
طبيعتها وبقرار من وزاره الداخليه
واستنادا الى الامر المتعلق بتنظيم حالات
الطوارئ سيتم بدايه من اليوم تحجير
الاجتماعات بمقرات حركه النهضه بكامل تراب
الجمهوريه الى جانب تحجير الاجتماعات
بمقرات جبهه الخلاص بتونس الكبرى باب
الفاتيكان فرنسيس ينضم رسميا للاخوان
المسلمين في تونس ففي جلسه التجلي مواليه
لسعيد ومتلفزه يؤكد والي صفاقص السابق
فاخر الفخاخ
ويصادق على كلامه ضيف اخر في الجلسه بان
نص عضه بابا روما التي لاحظ فيها تحولا
استبدااديا في تونس تفيد يقينا بان
الاخوان المسلمين قد كتبوا له العظه
ليلقيها في قداس عيد الفصح
ولتكتمل الروايه تم الاتفاق في نهايه
المقابله على ان باب الفاتيكان فرانسيس هو
قيادي في جماعه الاخوان المسلمين مش احنا
فقط
الاخرين عندهم
مفهوم المسيح
السلطه اللي قال ان اتخذت ناج استبدادي
فيما يتعلق معناتها بالوضع في تونس هذا من
التقارير اللي يقراها من جمعتهم من
الخونجيه نتاعهم ناكد لك سي بوبكر السيد
هذايا
غضب شعبي مغربي حل على وزير العدل عبد
اللطيف وهمي الذي اتهم بالمس بشرف
المغربيات عندما قال الجنديل كلمه زاد شيء
ذري نقلبه على باه يبغى المغربي غادي
يتابعوا 20 ذري ما بعرف اذا قلتها صح لكن
المقصود بالفصحى لو لجانا الى الحمض
النووي يقول لوجدنا ان لكل مغربيا عشرين
طفلا المفارقه ان وزير العدلي هذا هو
الامين العام لحزب يسمى بالاصاله فهل ترفع
اصاله نصري دعوا عليه كلهم
حقيقه علميه لا ياتي البطن
في المسجد
يبقى المغربي غادي يتابع 20 دري
مني لقد سبق تفلت وزير العدل بهذا الكلام
اطلاقه حمله لتشجيع المغاربه على الزنا
وليجمله في عقولهم وصفه بالعلاقه الجنسيه
الرضاائيه
في المجال الخاص اتجهنا نحو الغاء النص
الذي يجرب العلاقات في الفضاء الخاص
حتى في افلام بوليود الهنديه يحترم المخرج
الشرطه بلاده اكثر من ثلاثه شبان مجرمين
ادعوا انهم صحفيون لتطالب رصاصات مسدساتهم
راسي المعتقلين النائب السابق المسلم في
البرلمان الهندي عتيق احمد وشقيقه اشرف
احمد بينما كانت الشرطه ترافقهما لاجراء
فحص طبي لهما وهي تقيدهما
الخنازير والاصفاد فتحول البث التلفزيوني
المباشر لاسئلتي المراسلين لهما الى تغطيه
لمشاهد قتل نمتنع عن عرضها كامله نظرا
لقساوتها النائب السابق عتيق ليس جديدا
على عالم المحاكم فهو يواجه اكثر من مئه
تهمه بقضايا اجراميه وماليه بحسب القضاء
الهندي ما هي عقوبات القتل وتاسيس
العصابات المسلحه وحيازه الاسلحه للاجرام
وتقمص دور صحفيا بهدف القتل في دوله الهند
الديمقراطيه بابا مدير
القتله الذين استسلموا فورا للشرطه كانوا
يرددون شعارات دينيه هندوسيه يحيون فيها
الههم رام فهل هذا سيحولهم الى ابطال عند
المتطرفين في الحكومه وخارجها وتظهر
اللقطات التلفزيونيه المهاجمين وهم يرددون
شعارات هندوسيه بعد الهجوم الذي وقع في
المدينه الشماليه البلاد والقتلان من
الاقليه المسلمه في الهند لكن الشرطه لم
تعلن ان كانت تحقق في دوافع طائفيه وراء
الجريمه ام له في المتفرقات وفي العام
يعود جدار برلين بعناوين جديده مع ملامح
عوده الحروب القبليه الى الاوروبيتين
الشرقيه والغربيه فان فنلندا قد شرعت
بتشييد جدار فاصل على حدودها الشرقيه بعد
انضمامها الناتو وذلك خوفا من ازمه هجره
قد تفتعلها روسيا بحسب الاعلام الاوروبي
ايها العرب استعدوا الاتهام جديد لكم خلال
الاعوام المقبله اذا لم تسمحوا بالتحشيش
بشكل قانوني
فنوادي الحشيشه الاجتماعيه في الغرب قد
وصلت الى المانيا
حشش وتعاطى المخدرات بمسؤوليه شعار التوجه
القانوني الرقيق المشاعر لهذه
النواديوس
لعبوا كره القدم المغربي العالمي اشرف
حكيمي احبه الكثيرون فوق اعجابهم بادائه
الرياضي لبره الظاهر بامه في الملاعب
والمناسبات جديد اخباري بره بالوالدين
ازعج طليقته
فهي بعد ان تقدمت من المحكمه في فرنسا
بطلب الحصول على نصف ثروته ضمن اجراءات
الطلاق الذي طلبته من اشرف بعد اتهامه
بالاغتصاب ردت عليها المحكمه نعيما تعيشي
وتاكلي غيرها اشرف حكيمي لا يملك شيئا وكل
ثروته منقوله الى حسابات والدته فعلا
نعيما اما العطور بعد الحلاقه فقط تكون في
الطريق الى الطريق حيث كشف حساب ويلز الذي
يهتم باخبار المشاهير ان اشرف حكيمي قد
يحصل هو على نصف ثروه طليقته هبه ابوك في
المحاكم الاوروبيه بعد قرارها الانفصال
عنه وبعد ان رفعت دعوى قضائيه في المحكمه
انتظرت ابوك ان تحصل على نصف ثروه واملاك
حكيمي والصدمه الاكبر كانت عندما اكتشفوا
ان حكيمي لا يضع الاموال في حسابه البنكي
وانما يضعها باسم والدته من فتره طويله
وكذلك يفعل بنسبه لما يملكه من عقارات
[موسيقى]
ختاما تقول الاسطوره ان رجلين يقال
لاحدهما حق وينادى الاخر بالباطل خرج معا
ذات يوم في رحله بدبه واحده
فاتفقا على ان يركب كل منهما نصف مسافه
الرحله بدا الباطل بركوب الدابه ولما وصل
الى منتصف الطريق طلب اليه حق ان ينزل
ليسمح له بالركوب فاذا بالباطل يرفض ويكذب
ثم يطلب ان يحتكم الى اول عابر سبيل وافق
حق لانه صاحب حق لكن الباطل زيف الحقيقه
وسال اول العابرين سؤالا ماكرا برايك يا
اخ العرب من الذي يجب ان يمشي على هذا
الارض الحق ام الباطل فاجاب الرجل على
الفور طبعا الحق هو الذي يجب ان يمشي
دائما
الم يجد حق سبيلا للتفاهم مع الباطل الا
بالقوه فتمكن منه وقيده وجره وراءه مكبلا
الى قاضي المدينه
فطر مبارك والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
وحده يا ستي
والله
اودعاتكم رحله فلسطين ما ودعتك
م ما بنسى ارضي في قلبي والله
حورت صيني لكتب بالحبر عورك صيني
بكتب بدمي احبك يا فلادي بكتبي بدمي
[موسيقى]
يا فلسطيني على اللي جرى لك يا فلسطيني
لا لا تنهمي راسك بالعالي لا لا تنهمي
[موسيقى]